Bill Duke, actor/filmmaker/author: Well the
system is set up for the youth and all the
older ones who have survived, all the wisdom
we have now is irrelevant. I just have to
go ahead and sayGood luck.
When I was a young man there was a saying
I never forgot and it wasWhen I was a young
man, I thought my father to be a fool. Now
that I am older, oh how wise he has become.Because
when you’re young you think you know every
damn thing until life smashes in the face,
the truth of the indifference toward you and
all thoseoldpeople you think are two dumb
to listen to, once you get a couple of scars
you’ll see how stupid they really are, but
you’ve got to be scarred first.
Because us talking, you knowThey don’t
know nothing…nah…nah…nah…yap…yap…yap.
Your generation is in the past.But when you
get crushed, and by crushed I don’t meannotbeing
successful. Ask what the cost today of being
successful is? It’s coming out. So you have
success but you paid for it and so with that
success comes shame because you wanted success
more than your self-respect.
You notice all these people coming out now
and sayingThis is the price I paid. I’ve
been this miserable for all these years. But
thank goodness I can say Me.They took something
off me. Can you imagine being successful and
knowing the price you paid and choking on
it for the rest of your life.
Hey everybody I’m just fine. I’m great…I
don’t care about what I had to do except
when I sleep at night or can’t sleep at
night.Yeah, right.
Film Courage: What about wanting notoriety?
Bill:Notoriety…these days there are people
who will do anything for notoriety. Some of
the things I see on the Internet I sayAre
they really doing this?
He just pointed out to me yesterday [points
to a person off screen] a friend of his is
an artist, has been accused of it. But he
pointed out to me one of these women has a
website. And she has hundreds of pictures
of herself on the website, the most pictures
that you can imagine, the victim of the due
(who is getting no due process by the way)
because she said sohe’s guilty.
A friend of mine worked at a company for 15
years and a woman said that five years ago
he looked at her in a suggestive manner that
made her feel uncomfortable. They fired him
on the spot (they didn’t want the publicity).
So…these day people do things…acts…this
was on and he put up a selfie talking about
how he people and how he did it.
Then there are kids now and doing other kinds
of things online, saying how brave I am. Little
girls going to school (12-year-olds) with
in their backpack, people getting, being famous
now has taken the place of being of any kind
of self-worth. As long as you like me, I’m
okay. I don’t have to like myself because
you like me.
When you’re alone, doesn’t that bother
you? I don’t understand how
just having recognition or having people know
who you are or having a million eyeballs,
I guess that gives you identity these days.
And that’s just the beginning of the next
to generations.